matthew starts off this hour in
indianapolis hi matthew how are you
i'm doing well dave how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
so i'm 22 years old i make about 80 000
a year before bonuses i have twenty
thousand
in cash and then about fifty thousand i
have in etfs and mutuals
i'm getting ready to buy my first house
right now i know the housing market is
crazy
um my main question is is what my plan
to do
is take twenty five thousand dollars out
from my
investment account put that towards a
down payment do a 15-year mortgage on a
225 000
house is that a smart thing to do i
could take out more but i still want to
keep that emergency fund
but the arion man has projected about 10
increase in home values in the next year
dude you're a stud you're 22 and you're
making 80.
yes sir what do you do i'm a systems
engineer good for you man
you're killing it and you're single
correct are you uh dating someone
seriously
no sir i'm not okay all right
um the other question i do have is i
am i have a guaranteed at least ten
thousand dollar bonus next year and then
more than likely another additional 10
to 15 on top of that
so i should be slightly over a hundred
thousand for next year and
following years as well phenomenal okay
so uh i would just adjust your plan
slightly um because i know from the data
that we have
having studied 10 167 millionaires
that the typical millionaire has
two primary components to their first
million to five million dollar net worth
and you should be there by the time
you're 30 with the track you're on
okay and if you want to get there the
shortest way here's what the data tells
us
a paid for house and loading up the 401
k
correct i do max out my 401k company
good matches five percent
i put five percent in and then invest
the rest into etfs and mutuals good
so what that tells me is the paid for
house is the next thing on the equation
agreed
agreed which means i'm keeping only the
emergency fund i'm dumping the entire
etf
onto this onto this thing as my down
payment to thereby have less debt to
reduce
and then i'm going to throw bonuses and
money i would have been throwing in the
etfs
above the fully funded 401k at this
mortgage dude your house is paid for by
the time you're 25 26 years old
you got it and you're rolling into
a house at that point that's probably
worth 500
and um you know and let's just go ahead
and run the math out on your 401k
to you know for what eight years and i
think you're a millionaire
got it that's what i'm hearing i'm doing
this in my head pretty quick but i think
i'm pretty close
but uh and and here's the thing the
other thing that's going to happen is uh
you you statistically are very likely
during this eight year period of time to
meet and marry
the love of your life at which point you
will discover you have bought the wrong
house
right new plan new house
and so that will adjust our little plan
upset the apple cart but that's okay
it's worth it it's worth the cost
brother
[Laughter]
you'll still you're still gonna get
there because you got a plan but here's
the thing
the two data points are full 401k paid
for house and if you're always aiming
back at those at the earliest possible
age
you're going to build the greatest
possible amount of wealth
awesome that's for your first five
million dollars worth of
uh wealth and that's what a you know and
you know we call them everyday
millionaires or baby step millionaires
because they follow the baby steps
and i've met three out here in the lobby
today that followed the baby steps
over the last decade to 15 years and
been listening to this show one guy said
he'd been listening to the show 20 years
yeah you know and um he started doing
this stuff and he just you know got out
of debt
which gave him the ability to invest and
pay off his home